[Music]
i
am indeed here to talk to you um about
whiteness but maybe i should tell you
a little bit about myself first and why
i want to talk to you about whiteness
and first off um as i was introduced my
name is dr miriam fraser i'm a political
scientist by training with a phd
from oxford examining postcolonial
resistance
to western hegemony in north africa
and these days i work primarily as a
journalist and a documentary filmmaker
now just over a year ago i started a
podcast called we need
to talk about whiteness for those of you
who would like to listen to that you can
catch it on
spotify and itunes and the objective
really behind the podcast
was to explore the meaning of whiteness
why did i want to do that
well largely for personal reasons to be
honest
um i became increasingly aware in my
personal life that many of my friends
and loved ones
from non-white backgrounds were sharing
a sort of bubbling
frustration with the lack of racial
awareness
arrogance and entitlement they
frequently encountered in their day to
day
were still in many of those instances
other people
other white people were present in
witnessing these instances
but often stayed quiet like many of us
might do
you witness something that somebody else
does it feels uncomfortable
it looks wrong but you didn't do it so
it really doesn't feel like you have to
speak up
only it became increasingly obvious to
me that that's exactly what needed to
happen
that we could no longer leave the burden
of discussing
racism or racial injustices or calling
out racial injustices
upon the victim of those injustices and
in fact
those of us who were witnesses in many
ways
could end up looking like all being
silently complicit
if we didn't take a stand so
um some of these instances i thought i
would share with you
um to give you a sense of the sort of
deep frustration
i was experiencing listening to them one
was a very senior
black academic walking into her first
day in a
very prestigious new job at a big um
academic institution
and being instructed as she walked
through the doors to change the bins
please before she left
um because she was mistaken for the
cleaning lady
um and another occasion an asian film
producer friend of mine had been told
by a very senior film industry executive
that she should count herself lucky to
be at the table
and that she hadn't been on a killed yet
and that was received with rapturous uh
laughter
by the rest of the table and so what i
was hearing increasingly from my friends
that they
was that they were telling me they had
to hide or even shield
who they are in their workplace where
their racial and cultural identity
singled them out for differential
treatment the question was
and is different from what um
and as i delved a little deeper i came
across a term which first developed
um in critical race studies in america
whiteness and whiteness studies as
a whole field uh which grew out of um
studies uh in the u.s um so if you're
interested in learning more about that i
would look into
whiteness studies in america now what
does whitening studies do
they look at the historical and social
formation of white identity
i began reading up on it and realizing
that some of my favorite writers from
bell hooks to
james baldwin had in fact written about
whiteness and describing it in bell
hooks's words for example
as terrorism in reference to the fear
she experienced as a child
walking through a white neighborhood i'd
never really heard white
identity described in those terms in
fact what i realized was i'd never
really thought about
white identity i'd never really given
much thought to what it meant to be
racialized as
white because i'd largely assumed it was
a
neutral and meaningless identity
and what i realized was of course that
um
it had that whiteness is so normative
that it's so
um uh so deeply embedded
in our society that we uh as white
people are
rarely aware of its significance and
particularly if we're not listening to
how whiteness is experienced by those
who are excluded to it
what that meant is i felt uh the need to
confront that meaning to understand what
white racial identity means to
those excluded from it and to try and
understand that
as a signifier that i was carrying
unwittingly in my day to day
with clear implications for my
interactions but which i was largely and
remain in many ways
largely unaware of even as i talked to
you now
now one of the best uh quotes in this
area which i i
always refer to is david wallace foster
who refers to
the fish in water you know i describe uh
whiteness as the water you know one fish
is swimming along
um and crosses another fish and says uh
hey
uh hey how's the water today and the
other fish says
what water and that's basically how i
conceptualize whiteness in my days today
we're all swimming in it
um some of us are aware that it's there
and others um are
so uh used to it that we that we never
really give it another thought because
we're swimming with the current and it's
never
swimming against us now um
what i also came to realize that whilst
a lot of interrogation was being
placed upon my black or asian friends so
you know what's it like to be black or
how many times have i heard someone say
to one of my friends what's it like to
be an asian woman
uh and yeah i realize we so rarely
interrogate the meaning of white racial
identity so i started to get into a
habit of trying to ask people
you know so what's it like being white
um
not in a uh flippant way not um in a way
that was deliberately trying to be
confrontational but really trying to
assess
the you know people's reactions when you
start to ask that question
um and so my starting point really for
the podcast and for the website was to
explore the meaning of whiteness both as
it's conceptualized as those who are
racialized as white and those who are
not
now caveat and quite an important one um
is uh the idea that race of course is a
construct
there's no uh biological scientific uh
rootedness to
uh race race is a theory that was
developed
um to justify uh what i call race a
category of power and what i mean by
that is that it emerged
uh in a context in which uh different
groups needed to be
divided in order to advance the
interests of
what you know what was at that time the
one percent were probably still the one
percent
um and so uh in that sense uh although
race is a construct racism which is the
uh outcome
of that construct that was created to
justify
hierarchies of human value and then to
justify things like slavery and
colonialism and imperialism
and unequal treatment of people more
broadly in society along racial lines
um that continues to have a very real
world impact on people's lives even to
this day
um so what is whiteness well you'll find
a few definitions online if you want
i think of whiteness as an
interconnected system of power which
come
which from the personal to the political
asserts the supremacy
of white western europeans their ideas
structures
and actions and in so doing forms what i
refer to as a form of cultural myopia
which in discounting the value of
non-european output
is ultimately limiting self-serving and
harmful
to those excluded from those narrow from
this narrow perception of both the self
and the world so i think um whiteness as
a structure is harmful to everybody but
it's particularly harmful
to those who are excluded uh from it um
why me um well uh to those who might be
wondering what my racial identity is
um i'm half irish half french meaning i
am of european
heritage uh my religion is that i am a
muslim
and for most of my adult life i wore
a headscarf meaning that i was
identified
um as muslim in a way that perhaps
you wouldn't recognize it looking at me
now so
why did i want to begin this
conversation well um first off for
a very simple reason which is i believe
change has to start at home
within ourselves and this is an issue
that i have watched uh close friends and
loved ones grapple with
um for decades and it wasn't really
tenable for me uh to sit on the
sidelines and sort of
bemoan the situation or sort of say well
you know i'm not like that so it's fine
i sort of felt like well actually
um i may not hold those views or at
least i sort of don't think i do
but i'm sort of not actively um
challenging them
in my environment and that for me didn't
feel like a
um tenable long-term situation so i felt
a strong moral obligation to get in
on the pitch um and there's also another
more personal reason which is um i
suppose that as a muslim woman
who wore a headscarf for much of my
adult life i feel like i have
experienced
whiteness uh first hand meaning that um
when i wore herself more consistently i
was
regularly racialized as um excluded from
whiteness as non-white
um white uh people who uh identify as
white or identified as white would
frequently um
assume that i was uh not uh of the same
racial category and
um that led me to a whole load of um
interesting
uh and and quite worrying experiences
over the course of my life
um so what did it feel like what does it
feel like being um
excluded from whiteness and then um you
know having
the uh quote-unquote privilege of
slipping back into it well
what being excluded from whiteness felt
like to me was
like being an outsider and it felt like
being viewed with suspicion walking into
a shop having a security guard
follow me around it felt like having a
question mark having
uh hanging over my worth which needed to
be
proven in every interaction and
conversation whereas
others other people's worth was simply a
given
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas